tu sais qu'il était catcheur
l'inoventura avant oui je sais mais on
va voir une histoire de quelqu'un
d'autre dont il paraît qu'il aurait été
catcheur on regarde
ok le vrai faux journal la suite bonjour
En bon gros jovial il joue à nous amuser
chaque midi et pourtant sous son aspect
bon enfant le journaliste Claude Viller
cache bien son
jeu mais pourquoi tant de Haes Claude
Viller j'éta un petit garçon gros qui
bien sûr se faisait chauter à l'école
alors sans arrêt c'était la patate la
grosse et tout et un jour je me suis dit
il m'ennuie pour être poli je vais leur
casser la
gueule et pour faire les choses à fond
il est devenu catcheur professionnel on
arrivait sur scène avec sur scène pardon
on arrivait sur le ring excusez-moi on
sur le ring avec blouson noir clouté la
chaîne de vélo à la main et cetera
c'était la grande époque du catch Claude
Viller faisait trembler la France de
1958 à 1961 il fut l'un des quatre
frères masqués d'une troupe de catch
ambulant fait marquant il a toujours
joué le rôle du méchant malaimé mais
pourquoi Claude Viller vous savez c'est
le drame des gros le gros c'est celui
qui reçoit les poupilles dans le cul la
tarte à la crème dans la figure ah si
c'est le cocu c'est le c'est tout ça un
gros retournant pour la première fois
depuis longtemps dans un gymnase il
retrouve ses ancienses amours et égraine
ses souvenirs
é ce que je sais c'est que Chéry bébé en
revanche a terminé sa carrière comme
receveur des postes à can il médite
aussi sur les enseignements qu'il en a
tiré ça fait partie du rêve le catch
c'est pour moi c'est une manière de
raconter des histoires d'abord moi
j'aime bien raconter des histoires ça a
été les universités à
moi journaliste puis animateur de radio
les histoires il en raconte tous les
jours depuis presque 30 ans avec entre
autes le tribunal des flagrants délires
et son vrai faux journal aujourd'hui une
belle carrière qui laisse quelques
regrets à
certains en petit poids comme il était
ça aurait fait quelque
chose alors claud Viller catcheur avant
d'être journaliste s de l'info s de
lintox Jeane Morau à l'oreille
ouais c'est à toi jet le Bronson version
Far West à ton avis je dis que c'est de
l'info tu dis que c'est de l'info toi et
pourquoi je joue un peu sur les
probabilités ah ah c'est le premier que
je vois faire ça là jusquà maintenant et
toi alors également je d que c'est de
l'info vous vous m'avez dit c'était de
l' tox ah je suis inquiet là pour moi on
va voir Philippe est- de l'info est- de
l'intox ma pauvre Jean on a déjà un
couplet je crois qu'on en a deux c'est
totalement de l'info on
applaud C
bra les
journalist alors quel est le score
Laurent 2 pour le cowboy dis donc he
Philippe est-ce que tu as un commentaire
à faire et oui c'est de l'info Claude
Viller n'a pas vraiment un physique de
patineur artistique il est la preuve
vibrante et vivante qu'il ne faut pas
forcément coucher pour arriver dans ce
métier n'est-ce pas B
fille et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
debe abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu